Earvin melot's ki authored the flag the
poet and the song what's your book about
oh it's about though all those three
things
what's the flag the flag is the
star-spangled banner that the flag that
led to the composition of the poem that
became our national anthem really was a
particular object and this is about that
flag it's about the poem that was
inspired by that flag and about our
national anthem and the man who wrote
the poem that became the national anthem
all that in one book why do you think
somebody wants to read about this oh I
think it's a good story
I hope it's well told we need to get the
idea I didn't get the idea
up until very recently I was a reporter
at The New York Times the last 21 years
in the Washington bureau and I among my
assignments over the years has been the
Smithsonian Institution and I wrote
several pieces about the effort to
restore the flag that's pictured on the
cover of that book at the Smithsonian
and the last time I did a piece it was
in 1999 it was given a very big splash
in our science section a Corey Dean they
science editor liked the piece and run a
lot of pitches with it and it caught the
eye of an editor at Dutton man named
Doug grad and he called me up the next
day and he said I think there's a
there's a book in the story and I said
I'm your man but I'll check with the New
York Times first because it's a New York
Times story I did the stories in New
York Times reporter and they said fine
do it and so I did it in the middle of
your book there's a little story that
you say most Americans don't know about
and it's out of the war of 1812 come
about well which story do you mean
there's a lot of them there are why did
why did they burn Washington that that
was the biggest discovery that I made
obviously it's not a discovery to
serious historians of the subject but
the reason that the British
Washington was because it was in
retaliation for the Americans burning
what is to write today Toronto it was
then called York it was the principal
city in British Canada and the commander
of the British forces in the Western
Hemisphere gave instructions to his
forces that as soon as they could they
should do the same thing to Washington
that the Americans did to York I didn't
know that the Americans had even invaded
Canada let alone burned down their
capital what were we doing up there
we were a lot of people thought that
Canada was a good candidate to be one of
our state's a lot of people thought that
that would be one way of keeping the
British off balance is to attack them
before they British could attack the
United States it was never a very good
possibility that the United States could
conquer Canada but there were a lot of
people who thought that it would be good
for one thing
not too many years before that the
United States and the Jefferson
administration had engaged in the
Louisiana Purchase and a lot of that
territory would be naturally in the
south and they would be slave states
some anti-slavery people in the north
thought that if they could annexed parts
of Canada these would become northern
states there would be anti-slavery
states and that could balance against
any new slave states that came into the
Union how many American soldiers went to
Canada oh just a few thousand perhaps
they were led by among others general
Pike for whom Pikes Peak is named
general Pike had the misfortune of being
killed in the battle there the building
that held the explosives they dynamiter
of the black powder the weapons of the
British blew up they don't know whether
it was blown up because of a stray shot
got lucky from the Americans or whether
the British blew it up to keep it from
falling into the hands of the Americans
but it did blow up
and 30 or 40 Americans were killed
including general paik there's a quote
did you have in the book by a man named
Carl Ben yes
Carl Ben is the historian for the City
of Toronto decocting yes I did
he's a marvelous man and he was good
enough to read over that chapter for me
to test his critical eye on it and I
asked him why is it that Americans don't
know anything about the American attack
on Canada and he said that's the most
one of the most interesting things he
finds in Canada they ask people what
they've learned after tourists come and
visit the historic sites and in Toronto
and he said 80% of them said I didn't
know the United States attacked Canada
and if you walk out on the street here
today or North Capitol Street you'll
find nobody knows this maybe if they
read the book everybody will know well
there's another quote though from him
that I wanted to ask you about Carl been
Canadian says there is a strong
propaganda quality to American history
in the United States I don't think
there's another Western democracy that
abuses its history to affirm a nation's
goodness as much as the United States
does from our side of the border it's
all very amusing yes well but just
Canadians are reasonably amused
I don't know I I wrote that down because
he said it and I thought it was a very
good and strong point of view I don't
know if that's so we know for well the
Japanese are certainly not a Western
culture but there is a dispute that's
been going on since the end of World War
two the Japanese history books will not
acknowledge the Rape of Nanking they
will not acknowledge the use of comfort
women in Korea the French I don't know
what the French textbooks say but I
would be very surprised if the French
were not more chauvinistic than
Americans on that same page you have
down here that Francis Scott Key who had
objected to the war the 1812 war on
religious grounds yes he was against war
he was a
he was a pious man at least by his
contemporaries descriptions of him and
he didn't join up until the British were
actually in Chesapeake Bay so he put off
for a long time going to war he was
against going to war with Britain but he
did sign up with the militia and he did
participate as a young officer in a
principal battle here outside of
Washington called the Battle of
Bladensburg what was that the British on
their way to Washington defeated an
American army unit in Bladensburg and
you're a resident of this area you've
probably driven through Bladensburg many
times and not been aware that something
important happened there I certainly was
not aware of it it is a major battle
Scot seeds the historian at Fort McHenry
which is where most of the activity for
the star-spangled banner occurs Scott
said that Bladensburg was a very
important battle and he wishes that
Americans knew more about it what
happened there and why did it happen the
it was on over the road to to Washington
the the British were going to punish the
United States for the burning of Toronto
and when they got to Bladensburg the
Americans were waiting for them and the
British force was clearly superior and
put them to around James Madison who was
then the president was actually there
and was witness to this he had an
assistant a free black man and he sent
his assistant to the White House which
wasn't called the White House name but
we'll call it the White House what
didn't have his coat of white paint yet
he sent this man to the White House to
tell his wife Dolly Madison to pack up
and clear out because the Americans were
being routed and he didn't want dolly to
get caught by the British could be
pretty embarrassing circumstance but you
say it the White House that he was so
sure of himself that they had a the
dining room set up to feed 40 people
with its wine and everything explained
that
they the Americans were overconfident
they probably didn't have very good
intelligence as to how big they British
force was and they thought they would I
mean how are you gonna defeat captured
first of all his Secretary of the army
Secretary of War said that Washington
would not be a target so don't worry
about fortifying Washington what he was
fired soon thereafter so the Americans
were overconfident and as you say the
table at the White House was set for
dinner for 40 people and the wine had
been brought up from the cellar and it
was consumed but it wasn't consumed by
Americans it was consumed by the British
there's a point in your book where you
talk about Admiral is it Coburn he's at
points pronounced burn probably Cockburn
I don't know you know the Coburn
brothers who write for now to spell that
way but you're thinking about the port
and porters well I'm thinking about the
writers the Andrew and Alexander Coburn
who oh I'm thinking about another Coburn
where they they make port in from
Portugal Nate the British drink a lot of
it Admiral Coburn or Cockburn sat in the
Speaker's chair in the House of
Representatives and asked shall this
Harbor of Yankee democracy be burned
everybody said yes and they did it all
the Brady said yes burn everybody there
all the British knew that that was what
they were going to do how did he get to
the Speaker's chair he got in there and
there was there was nobody there
everybody fled this the city of
Washington was not prepared they thought
there was no real reason for the British
to attack Washington if there was no
strategic importance Washington had only
been the capital for at that point
twelve or thirteen or fourteen years
they were there were no there was a Navy
Yard in what is now south southeast
Washington there were all of the
buildings of government but there was
really no strategic reason they didn't
realize the
the propaganda value of one country
capturing the capital of another country
this was in 1814 when they actually
burned that's right how many American
soldiers were involved at that point and
would this be James Madison's finest
hour or one of his worst hours I don't
know exactly how many soldiers were
involved it was not a lot because as the
United States went into war did not have
a large army Teddy Roosevelt writing in
1882 blamed Madison and Jefferson for
getting involved in a war with the
world's greatest power and not having
anything to back it up Roosevelt was of
course a leading Republican of that day
and we think of them today as a leading
Republican Jefferson and Madison were
members of the party that evolved into
the Democratic Party today so you have a
case of a Republican political leader
criticizing the Democrats for not being
well-prepared militarily it's the same
thing that has happened in the twentieth
century
I remember when Ronald Reagan was
running for president against Jimmy
Carter one of the big things he said was
that Carter had let the armed forces run
down Teddy Roosevelt said that about
Jefferson and Madison what role is the
war of 1812 play in your whole scenario
in your book the war gets us to the
point of writing the anthem after the
British burned Washington their next
target was Baltimore which was a more
important target Baltimore Americans
don't think of Baltimore now as a major
city but in the 1810 census it was the
third largest city in the United States
it was important for shipbuilding it was
important for commerce the privateers
that sailed out into the Atlantic Ocean
to attack British shipping most of them
were made in Baltimore so Baltimore was
a larger military target and the only
way that the British could capture
Baltimore would be by sea by coming up
the Chesapeake Bay and up the Patapsco
River because they didn't have a large
enough land force to march from
Washington to Baltimore if they had had
enough in their armed force and their
army as opposed to their Navy forces
they could have marched from Washington
to Baltimore and captured Baltimore and
who knows what might have happened then
in the for the course of the war but
they didn't and in fact most of the army
that Britain sent to North America they
sent the candidate if they had sent
those people to the Washington area to
Philadelphia but they could have
captured who know they could have
captured most cities on the coast so
they didn't have enough land forces to
go the 30 or 40 miles from Washington to
Baltimore so they had to sail down the
Potomac into the Chesapeake up the
Chesapeake to the Patapsco and attack
Baltimore but they couldn't capture
Baltimore without going on land they had
to attack it they have attacked Fort
McHenry which is sitting in Baltimore
Harbor and that is where the flag was
that is where the flag was the Francis
Scott Key saw Francis Scott Key's saw
that flag after the great Battle of
Baltimore and that's what inspired him
to write down his poem which became the
star-spangled banner
he called it at first the defense of
Fort McHenry but the next day it was by
the next day was changed at the
star-spangled banner
it became an immediate hit everybody was
talking about it in Baltimore word of it
spread all over the United States and it
because soon became very popular the
poem the poem but it was said that it
was sung when Francis Scott Key was
sitting on a little boat in Baltimore
Harbor where all of this attack was
going on
he had in his mind a popular song of the
day it was called e and created Sawyer
to an a crayon in heaven that has two
titles it's a English drinking song and
Americans of the day wrote parodies
based on that song so he had this song
in his mind when he sat down and/or
stood and wrote the star-spangled banner
every word in his song exactly matches
the notes in the English drinking song
an aside figure that you give the
British had six hundred warships and we
had sixteen something like that yes how
many ships did they brought over here
well they couldn't bring them all over
and the beginning they can only send a
few over because they still had Napoleon
to deal with after they defeated
Napoleon then they could take all those
assets and start bringing over more so
the defeat of Napoleon was very bad news
for the American this there's one
Admiral you talk about an air british
admiral who had to watch the Napoleon at
Saint Helena yes he he was in charge of
he was Napoleon's babysitter he was one
of the people earlier in the American
campaign
can you imagine watching over in
Napoleon he was put in charge of an
island in the South Atlantic in the
middle of nowhere and his main duty was
to make sure that Napoleon didn't get
loose again because as you know he he
was once held in Elba and he was able to
get back to France and do mischief how
many years did you spend with any air
times 34 years what are you doing now I
well I don't know if this program is
broadcast later on we're we're taping
this now in July I am working as a
summer editor at the International
Herald Tribune in Paris I took early
retirement in April from the New York
Times after 34 years and our plan by my
wife Irish and I plan to live in Paris
for four months each year
we hope to spend a month in Italy every
year and then seven months back in
Washington each year and I will be a
contract writer for the New York Times
for the period that we're in Washington
so I am looking forward to a a very
active early semi-retirement how did you
get to the New York Times from what
location I've been in this paper man all
of my working life I was at Newsday on
Long Island immediately before going to
the New York Times and before news day I
was at a news newspaper in Trenton New
Jersey called the Torontonian and before
that I was a copy boy at the
Philadelphia Inquirer from about age 18
so I've done nothing else except
newspaper work so you're kind of limited
in the number of questions you can ask
about my professional career unless you
want to talk about the newspaper
business where did you grow up I grew up
in Camden New Jersey where'd you go to
school I went to Camden High School in
Camden New Jersey about college went to
Temple University in Philadelphia what
intrigues you about this business of
journalism I don't know like many people
in journalism like I didn't set out to
become a reporter or an editor it
happened I got a job as a copy boy at
the Enquirer and that paid for my
education at Temple University I worked
my way through school it's also where I
met my wife so that's pretty important
couple of things that I got out of
journalism a lot of my colleagues never
set out to become this paper people one
of them did obviously they went to
journalism school but I didn't and I've
never regretted being a newspaper
reporter or an editor and it's been very
enjoyable and very fruitful and I think
I've enjoyed it
what book is this for you it's my second
book I should say second and a half
I wrote a book about 15 years ago on
mail-order catalogs of all things the
half book that I wrote when I ghostwrote
wrote a book for a celebrity who then
neglected to give me credit for who was
the celebrity well let's not say why
didn't they give you credit for
she said she forgot so no one knows that
you wrote that book yeah well my wife
knows my kids know I got a flat fee for
doing it and I was able to pay for our
first vacation abroad from the proceeds
of that book so it was not a complete
loss
what intrigues you about Paris and Italy
Paris and Italy why do you want to live
there every sort of month plus what is
there not to like I mean the food is
wonderful
Paris is beautiful Italy is beautiful
and I still love Washington I can see
doing this for many years to have all of
these things have the possibility of
working at the Herald Tribune for four
months each year and having free time to
to explore Paris I think I don't know if
you had it but you had your your network
had Adam Gopnik
book on and he writes charmingly about
Paris I I would never write about Paris
because I'm I can't imagine spending
enough time there I could write about
Italy I hope to write about Italy
sometime it's old world
it's great food it's great wine these
watch wrong with it obviously they don't
do plumbing very well especially in
Paris you a smile of recognition there
back to your book the clock er the clock
er who's the clock er that's guy named
Zimmermann that
Sports Illustrated I was yes this is
picture I miss going to showing right
among the things I done for the New York
Times is cover sports and I was in
Robert F Kennedy Stadium a couple of
years ago for a Redskins game and they
were playing the star-spangled banner
the Redskins band was and I was in the
third row and I became aware that there
was somebody about two rows down yelling
faster faster
I had no idea who he was yelling to or
who he wanted to do something faster one
of the other reporters told me that this
was simmerman and that he clocks the
playing of the star-spangled banner for
every sporting event that he goes though
and his goal is to get to break the
record he wants the star-spangled banner
to come in at under 51 seconds and he'll
yell of course they can't hear him
there's 40 or 50 thousand people there
there's a band and he's way up there but
he's yelling for them to go faster and
you say that he's clocked twelve hundred
and eighty three sports events yes
that's one of those figures were you you
make it more precise to give it a an air
of verisimilitude did he have a watch
it's got a stopwatch and who's the
shortest ever to sing the star-spangled
banner I don't remember who this or the
singing was the shortest performance was
John Kiley the organist at Fenway Park
for many years I think Kylie came in the
fastest plenty of people have come in
slowest Pearl Bailey to two hours
I mean to 2 minutes and 28 seconds
probably felt like two hours of some
people yes and a rock singer named Leola
Giles - 2 minutes and 34 seconds yes I
missed that one too but I found I found
a record of it now what do you think is
a the idea of singing the star-spangled
banner at a sporting event it's
unnecessary the network's
have recognized that it's unnecessary
because for the entire season when the
star-spangled banner' is performed the
network's go and sell beer or telephones
or cars or tires whatever they sell so
the networks have recognized it and have
voted with their buttons that it's not
necessary why is it unnecessary why is
it unnecessary well there was one man I
found he said
Macy's doesn't play the star-spangled
banner every morning when it opens for
business its itself to me it's an
artificial form of patriotism we don't
need to have 50,000 people listen to a
band and Zimmerman probably is on the
right track there but our patriotism is
a lot deeper than listening to a
performance at a at a stadium if it's
like these car dealers with their
American flags on Washington's Birthday
or having a sale we were in Paris for I
think it was Ascension Day but it may
have been Pentecost a holidays that do
not get a lot of recognition in this
country but in a Roman Catholic country
like France it's a big holidays or big
holidays and my wife iris said isn't
this interesting in the United States a
holiday would be a cause for Macy's
sales and things like that but in France
and I imagine in the other countries in
southern Europe like Italy in Spain that
people actually take the day off and
they don't go to work and we do it just
the opposite in this country and I feel
the same way I think about using
patriotism for commercial gain like that
for radio stations and television
stations where 24 hours a day they'd
always begin and end the day with the
star-spangled banner
right I'd forgotten about that I if I
had remembered that I would have put it
in the book well I'm old enough to
remember working a radio station I used
to do that as a question to use it was
that necessary
no of course not well when do you need
it then when do you use your star spine
I think if you use it for really
important events then it becomes more
meaningful hey it's not meaningful if
that when they play it a hundred and
sixty two baseball games and the players
they they tell the players be careful
where you scratch yourself because you
know the sitting there waiting for it
standing there waiting for it to be over
they've got all these people watching
them and gotta be careful what you do
nobody's paying much attention you know
and in Baltimore they pay attention
because there's a line when they all
yell Oh at the same time and I'm told
that in Atlanta in the line the home of
the brave
they make it the home of the Braves got
it
so they do a pay attention they're there
they don't pay attention most most of
the places people are not getting beer
hot dogs and I think it loses a lot I
play it at the opening night of the
Opera well they played opening night
that's that's all right
they played at opening day of the
baseball season that would be all right
and for the World Series and for the
all-star game the other day which I
missed for some reason that was not big
news in France Cal Ripken hit a home run
they would not a whine about it in the
French papers what about the flag where
did that come from the flag that were
speaking of for just the original
American flag the original American flag
was not done by Betsy Ross if this is
Europe your subtle way of indirection
what I mentioned that I was from Camden
New Jersey
usually people arts their eyebrows when
I say Camden New Jersey you're one of
the first people who has
Camden is across the river from
Philadelphia and when I was a boy my
father took me to the historic sites
many times to Independence Hall and he
took me many times to Betsy Ross's house
so it never occurred to me to a question
that Betsy Ross didn't do the first why
she didn't do the first place there's no
evidence that Betsy Ross ever made a
flag the first mention of it was by a
descendant of her as many years after
she was dead but it's a story that
caught on I think we like legends not
just our society it's easier to identify
with a legend Rome was founded by
Romulus and Remus and such a good legend
Betsy Ross made the flag no absolutely
no evidence that she did where does that
come from from her grandson her grandson
wrote in the mid 19th century that his
grandmother was commissioned by George
Washington to make the first American
flag actually no evidence that that ever
happened he would bask in the reflected
glory of his grandmother how he got that
notion and I don't know I I did enough
research into that one paragraph to be
able to say with some confidence that
Betsy Ross didn't make the first flag
but there's a bridge between New Jersey
and Philadelphia called the Betsy Ross
bridge so if you tell a good enough
story enough you'll get a bridge named
after you is there a bridge named after
Pickers Gil no not that I'm aware of
this is Mary Pickersgill yes this is one
of our one of our heroes she actually
did make a flag now it wasn't at the
Revolutionary period which is what Betsy
Ross is associated with
she is the one who sewed that flag
that's on the cover of the book the the
picture was taken in 1873 so was in
black and white the publisher took a
little bit of a liberty to make the
cover more colorful by putting in the
red stripes in the blue field but that's
the flag that Mary Pickersgill sewed in
Baltimore in August of 1814 so that it
would be able to be flown at Fort
McHenry because the commander at Fort
McHenry one of the biggest flag he could
get and he would show to the British
because he knew an attack was coming so
he could show to the British that the
Americans were still there and that they
were not going to be able to defeat him
and his fort and they would not be able
to capture Baltimore and he was right
he was a little bit of arrogance on his
part he wanted the biggest flag he could
get and he got it where did the Stars
and Stripes come from originally whole
idea I have no idea
one of those things that we've lived
with for so long I've never even thought
to ask about it we do know that there
were thirteen stripes for the original
colonies and the original flag had 13
stars but why somebody thought Stars and
Stripes could make a good combination I
have no idea it was obviously an
inspired choice because if this the flag
the American flag stands out so much but
maybe it's because our nation has been
so successful that it stands out but
there's something about that combination
if you look at the flag on the cover
there it had 15 stars and 15 stripes
because by that time there were more
than 13 states in the country there were
actually 18 at the time of the
or of 1812 but Congress had halted the
practice of adding a star and a stripe
for every new state at that point and
about seven years later Congress got
into the habit of adding a star every
time a state join the union and world
enough to remember Hawaii and Alaska but
they went back to the original 13
stripes can you imagine if we had a flag
with a 50 stripes so it looked like
pinstripes it wouldn't have the majesty
that it has now this flag that's on the
cover is that the one that was at the
Smithsonian that's right
and you started by telling us that the
fellows that Dutton have asked you to
write this book got it from the story
you wrote about those that flies yes in
the new york times why is that a story
why is that you know the original that
that fly get to Smithsonian a story
right now because there is a great
amount of concern that if they don't do
something if they don't arrest its
deterioration that it'll fade away it'll
disintegrate and because of its iconic
status as the flag that inspired our
national anthem they've been able to get
enough commercial support donors to pay
for the what will wind up to be a fair
amount of money it was talking about
tens of millions of dollars you said 18
yeah but you know how it is in
Washington Brian that's that's not we
start they they have to clean it in the
early 20th century that was mounted on a
linen backing and for all the years that
we saw it at the Smithsonian it was
displayed vertically flag really should
be res almost displayed vertically and
we only saw one side of it the other
side was covered by this linen backing
and millions hundreds of thousands of
stitches you say 350,000 an enormous
number who touch this may be like the
number of time
that somebody has clocked the
star-spangled banner' one of those
numbers hard to count so many of those
the stitches are linen the flag the
stripes are wool the blue field is wool
the stars are cotton the dye on linen
fades at a different rate than the dye
on wool so over the years imperceptibly
and perceptibly the guy on the linen
threads faded and a gloves like effects
developed that you wouldn't know from
looking at it the researchers said that
when they removed all of that the linen
threads the colors came more alive they
could see them without this haze of all
of those little pieces of women thread
in the way somebody said to me the other
day that they may never hang that flag
again that they have trouble they don't
know the one of the things one of the
things they have to decide is what to do
a flag has two sides we've only seen
that one side for all these years they
have to decide how they're going to
display it well they may have this that
decided something since the book came
out and since I've been in Paris
that's quite possible somebody mentioned
something about reading something in the
Washington Post but I as I mentioned to
you before we started I practically just
got off the plane so I'm not really up
to speed on what's been happening with
the flag in the two months since I've
been gone do you think it's worth
spending 18 million-plus on restoring a
piece of cloth well that's a good
question what are our priorities I'd
spend it why because of the symbolism
because of what it represents
it it was a turning point in our history
I wouldn't go so far as to say that if
balton
was lost we're lost the America would
have lost the war of 1812 certainly
Americans would be learning more about
it today Americans don't know anything
about the war they think well what did
happen at the end how did the war end
the war the most important battle of the
war was forth after the war ended the
Americans and the British were
negotiating in Ghent which is where's
Jen Jen is in Belgium today in 18 14 15
it was part of the Dutch nation after a
lot of negotiation the war was ended
everybody agreed war is over so word
came over on ship and while word was
coming over that war was over the
British had tapped New Orleans which is
one of their big mistakes not only if it
was a mistake because it was after the
war was over there isn't no it was it
was a terrible outcome the British lost
oh I don't have the figure in front of
me something on the order of 1600 men
dead and the Americans lost 12 something
like that the Americans were led by
Andrew Jackson which helped his career
obviously Andrew Jackson had an army
that was made up of local people from
Louisiana army people Navy people and a
contingent of free blacks and Theodore
Roosevelt who I mentioned earlier had a
really keen observation on the use of
free black soldiers because the British
ended slavery around 1806 the United
States of course had slavery yet that
pointed up until the Civil War here was
a large contingent of free blacks
defending New Orleans defending a way of
life that was keeping people of their
race in slavery Roosevelt writing in
1882 found a great deal of irony in that
I can understand why I enjoyed very much
reading Teddy Roosevelt the views of the
war of 1812 what about the designer not
irony or not but you point out that
Francis Scott Key had owned slaves
Francis Scott Key owned slaves and he
was a member of the Colonization Society
this was an organization of people who
wanted to free the slaves
but not to let them remain as American
citizens but to resettle them in Africa
in what is today Liberia completely
losing track it was a racist night it
completely loses track of the fact that
most of these black slaves were not from
Africa they were born in the United
States and this Colonization Society
wanted to remove them from the United
States have them resettled had them
settled ivory settled have been settled
in in Liberia the capital of Liberia is
Monrovia named after the president has
succeeded Madison so a fair number of
blacks did get their freedom and were
able to go to Liberia I imagine if you
tell the black person a slave well you
could stay as a slave or will let you go
to Liberia my most be question it's
given that choice would go to Liberia
but these slaves should have been
released we had to fight a whole civil
war that's a whole difference
so Francis Scott Key wrote in the
star-spangled banner that this is the
land of the free and home of the brave
the land of the free and he had slaves
you know and I watched your program over
the last few years when you did the
president's just tick them off on your
fingers George Washington had slaves
Adams did not Jefferson had slaves
Madison it slaves Monro had slaves John
Quincy Adams did not energy Jackson did
I know that some people will say this is
2001 we can't judge those people by our
standards today but I I think to my mind
is inescapable Jefferson said he wanted
them this slavery to be against the law
he I guess that's because of there's an
economic basis to slavery in that regard
he wanted to enjoy living a good life
but he couldn't enjoy a good life if he
freed his slaves and his competitors
didn't there's an economic basis to a
lot of history shadow is it not until
1931 and Hoover's time that the national
anthem was adopted what does that mean I
mean it was the poem was written in 1850
1414 and it took till 1931 to decide our
national anthem well that's we did not
have a national anthem how did it work
how do we get there we got a national
anthem because there was heightened
patriotism during World War one the
soldiers who were in World War one came
back the Army and the Navy had adopted
that the star-spangled banner as their
official song is let's say in around
1895 so these American soldiers who came
back would now be very familiar with it
as an anthem and the Veterans of Foreign
Wars and other patriotic and veterans
organizations began a campaign soon
after the war ended in 8th in 1918
and it took them until 1931 to persuade
Congress to adopt the star-spangled
banner' as the national anthem until
then we did not have one boy there are
other songs in the running yes America
the Beautiful which still gets a lot of
support today a lot of people find it
easier to sing anybody tried to change
our national anthem and the last step
seven eighty years sure last 10 15 years
I've I've written about congressman
Hill introduced bills and I went over my
clips I was working on this book and I
found something that I wrote in 1984
interviewing a congressman and he said
mark my words America the Beautiful will
be the national anthem by the year 2000
well he's not in Congress anymore we
still have the same national look is
there folklore that's been created over
the years about this song how hard it is
to sing and well you know it's hard
listening everybody I was right but the
range is too great it's about an octave
and a half the only people who can sing
it without butchering it switching
octaves are people with trained voices I
interviewed Robert Merle
of the Metropolitan Opera / New York
Yankees for the book he loves the song
he says he is inspired by it
he likes America the Beautiful too but
Robert Merle would ever want us to stop
star-spangled banner' as our national
anthem see Francis Scott Key first of
all what what was his profession he was
a lawyer in Washington in Washington
another Washington lawyer story went to
st. John's a little school up in
Annapolis that's really great book
school that's right what impact did he
have on that school he had a great
impact on that school he helped save it
from going out of business he was an old
boy in a grad and it fell on hard times
when he was in his maturity I guess in
in the 1820s or thereabout it had
received support from the state of
Maryland which then withdrew the support
and key rallied
the former grad the ex rads the grads of
st. John's to rally round and keep st.
John's functioning and as you know it's
today one of the finest small colleges
in the United States the flags you say
played an important role in the Civil
War yes
flag did not have what I call an iconic
status until the Civil War proof of that
is people took pieces of the flag as
souvenirs they did not regard it as a
sacred object at the Smithsonian they've
made a verb out of souvenir they say
people souvenir the flag the man who was
the commander of the fort major Armstead
Armistead took possession of the flag
after the war and evidently people came
up to him after the war of 1812 and said
could I have a piece of the flag took of
a piece the flag Museum in Baltimore has
eight or nine pieces of the flag that it
has acquired over the years and that's
why it's not as big today as it was when
it was made it was a gigantic flag was
made it still gigantic but it's lost
several feet what's the biggest Flags
ever been made oh there was some flag it
had to be in California right it was
must be ten times the size of this flag
in fact it was in Washington ten years
ago or so I must have been off that day
but I didn't say it but a little little
tidbit that we threw in the book it's in
the if anybody is really interested the
largest flag in the world can be found
in the Guinness Book of World Records
when you went about finding out the
material for this but first of all when
did you start doing your research well
soon after my article appeared this
would have been in the spring of
nineteen
Denine where did you go where were the
different places you had to go in order
to do your research much of the research
was done right here right down the
street at the Library of Congress a lot
of the research was done in Baltimore
what do you think of that facility over
there what didn't Fort McHenry have a
Fort McHenry is marvelous anybody who is
ever on holiday in Baltimore or somebody
on a holiday in Washington and has to go
north on i-95 to get to say to
Philadelphia to New York just stopped
off there for a couple of hours it it's
so important to our history and the
people there Scot seeds and Audubon
launched two of the park rangers that I
spoke to were just fantastic
they couldn't do more for me they just
said you want this they copied this for
me records from the fort to go into the
book then the other major source of
information that I had and we haven't
gotten into this was on the British side
I called a friend of mine or sent an
email to her in London and I said will
you please do some research on for me on
Robert Bruce and he's a historian and
she said the only Robert Ross I know was
the good friend of Oscar Wilde I said no
not that Robert West
I said that's Brigadier General Robert
Ross she said well I can't do it but
I've got a friend John Mason and John
Mason went to the regimental records the
units that general ruff was with and we
got some really good stuff from there
and so that was another principal area
Ross who we haven't gotten into
was the commander of the British land
forces he's the one who brought the
troops into Washington so they could
burn it and he is the general who led
them on the attack of Baltimore the
fleet dropped off their army units at a
place called North Point 15 miles below
Baltimore and the unit marched up to try
to capture Baltimore very soon a sniper
shot general Ross and killed him led the
Duke of Wellington to say that he
questioned the wisdom of having his
generals at the head of their troops
Ross was an inspiring leader when he was
in here in Washington he had his horse
shot out from under him he was very
tough on horses
I found three other references to horses
being shot out from under General Ross
he was a commander in the Peninsula
campaigns against Napoleon and he got
shot a couple times got got hit in the
chops as he put it in a letter to his
wife and he said that after the Battle
of Baltimore he was going to return to
his wife and had never go to war anymore
but a sniper got him
and it's so depressed the British troops
that someone wrote alone went up in the
ranks and they lost their will to fight
who knows if Ross had not been killed I
can't say that the war would have had
another outcome that's the what-ifs
school of history and I can't deal with
that but he was a marvelous character
and the person I never heard of until I
started doing research on the book and
until my friend's colleague in London
got the regimental records as you know
it's this small book as books go and
hold it up
couple 237 pages sells for $22 was there
a decision made to keep it small it was
my decision it's it doesn't have as many
words in it as I contracted for
and this was pointed out to me by the
publisher and I said I've said what I've
had to say I think if I did more that
would be padding can't we just end it
here and maybe I was persuasive maybe I
was stubborn but we ended it or I ended
it so what's the value of a book like
this for somebody I think it's a good
story
I in my new life as a sometimes
freelance writer I agreed to a piece on
the new visitor center at the Capitol
for the magazine of the Pew Charitable
Trusts and they asked for an author's ID
and I wrote I wanted to promote the book
and I wrote that I was a former New York
Times person and I've written this book
and I said it's a history of the
star-spangled banner' and I'm about a
day later it occurred to me I don't want
to call it a history so I wrote back
email is wonderful since I could he know
I said can you change that from a
history to a story and he had a good
sense of humor he wrote back he said you
mean you want to be known as a
storyteller and not as a historian and I
said yes so he said fine well let me go
back then to that quote I write earlier
from Carl Bern then I'm sorry Ben BNF
there is a strong propaganda quality to
American history in the u.s. I don't
think there's another Western democracy
that abuses its history to affirm a
nation's goodness as much as the United
States does from our side of the border
it's all very amusing Carl been running
the Toronto City History Museum
yes he's the he's the curator the
historical curator for the city in your
life of writing how often have you found
American Historians to embellish the
situation
to not tell the real story oh I I don't
know that I agreed that an American
historian set out to embellish American
history the story of the war of 1812 is
hardly touched on when you and I were in
school so maybe it's natural that if
it's hardly ever touched on it some of
the things that I think now are
important
we're not mentioned like the American
attack on Toronto and the American
attempt to conquer Canada they also the
Americans also burns what is now a
Niagara in Canada and several other
places I never knew that and I'm hoping
that might as you put it my little book
will go inform some people of this
unusual event how badly did the British
burn the United States Capitol and the
White House well they it completely
burned the the difference between the
American attack on Toronto and the
British attack on Washington is that the
British commander said just burned
public buildings the American commander
gave no such order
he said burn the place they burned the
place there was a lot of looting the
Americans broke into the city jail let
the people out and they joined in the
looting many private houses in Toronto
were burned down and none in the in
Washington right now the book I hope so
got a subject yes a couple of subjects I
would like very much to write a book
about Italy with my wife because I think
if I have some writing ability and
if I combined that with her knowledge of
Italian food and Italian art I think it
could be quite a combination we have to
persuade a publisher that it would be a
good book to publish because there are
more than one book on Tuscany on this
could your local bookstore shelves today
someday I'd like to do a book on my home
town of Camden New Jersey which I'm a I
regret to say today is the worst city in
the United States and I would like to be
able to say how it got that way I don't
know if I'll be able to say how it could
be fixed I don't know if I have the
answers but I could certainly say how it
got to be in such a sorry state that
it's in here's the cover of the book the
flag the poet and the song and as urban
mullets key our guest says the story of
the star-spangled banner thank you very
much thank you for having me